okay this is my first solo cooking demo
so i'm not gonna lie i'm a little
nervous and excited but you know what
when everything is calm and normal means
you've done it so
fear a healthy amount of fear is good
all right
thank you um what i wanted to cook for
you guys today is a pasta that is really
near and dear to me i could eat pasta
every single day of my life
i have the metabolism of a sloth who's
asleep at the switch
so unfortunately i cannot i love food
but what i've tried to do because i've
been like on a wrecking ball pendulum
swinging back and forth heavy thin heavy
thin like
for me you know everybody's body is
different there is no diet one size fits
all
and i also think that i've tried to
educate myself
to make healthy alternatives of dishes i
love
because when i was doing the chicken and
broccoli type of diet with working out
all the time
here's what happened i would go off the
rails and then my pendulum would swing
all the way that way
so i've tried to find foods that
actually are just like the foods i love
but very healthy versions of them so i'm
gonna make a spaghetti today that's
actually made with secret ingredient
chickpeas
okay this pasta has changed my life
and the truth is the way we digest food
is
a lot of gluten-free and rice
alternatives to pasta are a little
inflammatory
so with this sauce this is just a simple
sauce and i always wanted to be that
kind of guy who like
made simple sauces at home but i'm not
like sexy in the kitchen i'm a little
bird brained
but this if i can do it trust me anyone
can do it
i also love cooking solo so i love when
recipes give
the right ratios for that so if you go
on our website you're going to be able
to get this for four to six but also one
to two
jose andres is on the show and he said
throw your garlic in
with the peel on and that way it won't
burn
turns out he's jose andrus for a reason
i've been doing it now and it has
changed my game
all right so we're going to get this
going and when your oil is sort of
sizzling you're going to take cherry
tomatoes the longest thing
honestly yeah oh i told jose andres i'm
also turning my heat down okay calm down
the longest thing that actually takes
here is cutting the cherry tomatoes this
whole sauce should take
10 minutes so i love layering this pasta
can also be made as fresh as you want
or it can be made as a complete pantry
dish
all you have to do is take your dried
spices so i've got cherry tomatoes
basil salt now my secret tip is i love
a little harissa paste it's a tunisian
spice
and i do sort of like lima bean size
things in there and it adds this nice
smoky spicy
i don't have a thing all right i'm going
right in here
and literally this is it if you have
dried herbs you can do oregano parsley
you could even do chopped tomatoes in a
can
this can really be a staple any time
that you want it all right
i'm also going to do a little tomato
paste just
again little sort of lima bean size
dollops right in there and then you're
just going to keep cooking it down
and eventually the cherry tomatoes will
just sort of break open but they'll
remain intact enough
and you're gonna have what looks like a
restaurant dish
and like i said if i can do this anybody
can do this
another thing that's really great about
this if you would like to add meatballs
go for it because the way digestion
works
is that it doesn't process meat
proteins and grains very well but
because this is a chickpea flour
your stomach welcomes proteins with it i
also love to rock a little digestive
enzymes you can find these in
any health food store or grocery yeah it
just aids with digestion
and since i started eating this way i've
actually maintained the same weight
and that is my secret i have found a way
to have pleasure in the kitchen and
my body is happy and it's responding
with like
something that feels really good and
empowering and i'm not deprived i'm
totally enjoying myself
shout out to the pasta queen my friend
who's a maven on tick tock
she says to take your ladle to get the
ultimate in
bird's nest and it really works look at
this if this was a bowl
it's like perfect so shout out to her
ta-da
all right i'm gonna taste it i hope that
you guys have enjoyed the show oh
beauty shot oh god i already messed up
the beauty shot well
i hope that you take all the goodness
um that we're feeling here with you
throughout the rest of your day that's
what we're really here for is to just
spread good energy and good cheer and
enjoy life
and find what all the things that are
worth just
being human for so thank you very much
for joining us today